As long as the cell doubles its DNA before dividing, then each daughter
cell will have the same amount of DNA information as the parent cell did.
>> Sounds like a pretty important step, that
all the genetic information stays intact for every division.
>> Exactly. We call this kind of division, mitosis. Mitosis
is a kind of division where the same amount of
information is maintained over many cell divisions. So it's important
to keep two copies of the chromosome in every cell.
>> Right. This is how a heterozygous cell, where one
copy of the chromosome has one allele and the other copy
of the chromosome has another allele, when they divide and
have daughter cells, both the daughter cells will also be heterozygous.